imagine a soldier the size of an insect
the ultimate secret weapon you give that
like powers to everyone it's gonna be
chaos so how do we stop by knowing I
Scot I've been watching you for a while
you're different and I believe everyone
deserves a shot at redemption do you
absolutely my days of breaking into
places and stealing stuff are over
what do you want me to do I want you to
break into a place and steal some stuff
make sense are you ready to become a
hero now this suit has power
you have to learn how to control it
and these are your greatest allies
they're kind of cute
you're small you have superhuman
strength
you like a bullet
so you need to know how to punch you
only show me on a bunch show me how to
punch that's how you punch you tried to
hide your soup from me now it's gonna
blow up in your face then destroy
everyone you care about
get out of here
did you think you could stop the future
you're just a thief
no I'm ant-man I know wasn't my idea
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
ant-man trailer so this is gonna be a
breakdown video that also explain how it
fits in the MCU Marvel adjusted age of
Ultron press conference where they gave
up a lot of details about you know
thematically where ant-man is supposed
to fit with all these big Avengers films
so six billion dollar question where
does this movie fit with all the other
big stuff Kevin Feige said that this is
like a bookend for Phase two it's like a
different kind of bookend because
technically age of Ultron is the last
phase to film what this does is fill in
a lot of the gaps from the 60s 70s and
80s in the Marvel Universe the movies
and the TV shows haven't spent a lot of
time in those decades like we've seen
agent Carter which is like the very
beginning but we haven't seen a lot of
the middle stuff that's where Hank PIMs
character comes in so you learn what's
been happening between agent Carter and
like that first Iron Man film the film
itself takes place after Avengers age of
Ultron they said that a lot of the
decisions that Hank Pym makes in the
movie is based on what happens at the
end of age of Ultron I think the same
thing can be said for yellowjacket the
villain here
this trailer really explains the story
the movie in a much bigger way than the
previous trailers have yellowjacket is
now at the head of PIMs company Pym is
like the old man that's kind of been
pushed out his daughter hope Van Dyne
very much involved with the day-to-day
stuff imagine a punchy er kicker version
of Pepper Potts Evangeline Lilly awesome
in The Hobbit movies I think she has
high potential to wind up in a future
Avengers film like in Avengers 3 what
I'm hoping is is that once they steal
back the Yellow Jacket suit they'll
modify it and she'll wear that and
become the wasp and everybody misses
Janet Van Dyne but they said they would
explain where she is in this movie most
of these tech looking shots are from
inside Pym tech with the exception of
Hank pins lab they do good job of
showing the scale of like how ant-man
gets stronger as he gets smaller it's
the same principle behind the strength
of ants so he can kick the [ __ ] out of
people when he's super small even even
though he's a weakling when he's
normal-sized a big thing with the movie
and what's gonna lead up into Avengers 3
is that even regular people can be
heroes too that's kind of what's going
on - daredevil right now you know
street-level heroes Scott Lang is just
another twist on that even dirtbags can
be heroes I don't know if I call him a
dirtbag but I think it's a better
description of where his character
starts out but the movie explains his
origin story about about how he steals
to support his
so he's a dirtbag out of necessity as
they explained Yellowjackets plan is to
create an army of ant men in order to do
that he needs Pym particles like you can
build the suits but in order to shrink
you need the Pym particles he
appropriates that from Pym their
disagreement over that is what leads to
the heist I love all these Hank Pym
scenes like this is in PIMs lab you get
it you get a sense that he's been doing
this for a long time he's been the
ant-man for a long time
that's why the Yellow Jacket suit looks
more contemporary and the ant-man suit
looks like it was built 20 years ago
whenever you guys go see the movie make
sure that like and all these Hank Pym
lab scenes you keep your eyes peeled
they're probably full of Easter eggs if
you're a hardcore Hank Pym ant-man fan
these would really be your moments it's
like in Game of Thrones where they tell
you about Robert's rebellion like this
big adventure that you don't see like
they just tell you about it after the
fact Hank Pym is probably gonna explain
a lot of what he's been doing the last
20 years with the ant-man technology
I'll be interested to see how true his
character is to his comic book character
because I was thought of him as like a
crazier mad version of Tony Stark
like Tony Stark with grayer morality all
these really small sized scenes do a
really good job of showing this scale
you had the real world shrunk down here
and then in the other ant based scenes
you see him inside an ant farm really
the hard sell of this movie isn't so
much the suit we understand super suits
shrinking isn't that big of a leap it's
really his ability to communicate with
ants that they need to explain I feel
like if you read comics it's not a big
deal you totally get it you're like okay
he could just he can talk to ants the
problem with the big Marvel movies is
that they had to explain this stuff to
people that have never read comics
before if they're like why is he talking
to ants I don't get it
I like that hope tells him he's kind of
like a bullet when he's small like he is
as strong as a bullet it seems that
they're trying to build some sort of
relationship between the two characters
which is why they went with hope instead
of Janet I think it's a nice twist on
like the the Pepper Potts Tony Stark
relationship this is a nice shot of them
messing with Pym particles I'm looking
forward to seeing how the movies explain
those versus the comics the comics are a
little opaque with the way they explain
them there's this new type of particle
that allows you to do these things
it's like inventing vibranium because
you need a super strong metal they don't
get too deep into the mechanics of
vibranium there is just like a
one-sentence explainer super strong
metal okay we get it
I think this
train scene was inspired by the lego
movie probably like the most funniest
moment in a Marvel trailer that I've
seen in a long time aside from science
brofist really the job of this movie is
to sell the Scott Lang character they
can do action great like Marvel has
action down a hundred percent that's the
easy part the hard part is making us
believe that Scott Lang could go
toe-to-toe with Tony Stark Thor all the
other Avenger characters or that he even
deserves to be in their company but as
you can see from this train scene this
is probably gonna be the funniest Marvel
movie that you've seen so far
I mean Avengers age of Ultron has a lot
of funny moments Joss Joss Whedon is a
comedic genius but from the ground up
ant-man is built more on comedy that I
think the Avengers are speaking of which
actually transitioning to into Avengers
age of Ultron stuff so I'm gonna be
seeing an early screening next week so
what I'm gonna do is post a non-spoilery
review of that after I see it be sure to
subscribe to get it I know international
people you'll be seeing it sometime next
week too so just be careful with
spoilers whenever I post that video I
also wanted to give you guys a giant
high five and say thank you for the
almost 30,000 followers on Twitter and
15,000 on Facebook if you guys don't
know where to find those links there
into the description below
sometimes I'll live tweet TV shows if
I'm not already working on a video so
you guys want to have fun and play along
you can follow me there I'm still
working on more daredevil videos I'm
gonna try and slip those in between the
other TV shows that are coming back this
week so we have new episodes of Gotham
agents of shield flash and arrow so I'll
try to squeeze the rest of my daredevil
videos in in like the next week or two
if you guys haven't been watching it
seriously find a way it is amazing some
of you guys have asked me how to submit
fansubs for videos if you want to do
that for a video all you have to do is
go into the the closed caption menu
it'll have an option for adding
subtitles the other way would just be to
type up a transcript and then message it
to me on my channel thank you so much
though people that submit fansubs it's a
huge help over 50 percent of you guys
live outside of the United States which
i think is just awesome so in case you
guys haven't seen it or you're not cut
up yet you can click here for my Game of
Thrones episode 1 review from last night
it's gonna be a crazy season seriously
you guys need to watch it and you can
click here for my latest daredevil video
also probably best new TV series Marvel
has thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you